JASON CRANE: Good afternoon,
and welcome to Zagat Guest
Chefs at Google.
My name is Jason Crane.
And it's my pleasure to welcome
Laura Werlin here today.
Laura Werlin is the James Beard
Foundation award-winning author
of six books on cheese.
She is a sought after speaker
at food and wine events
across the country and is
a champion of all things
American cheese.
Laura is a frequent
teacher at the Cheese
School of San Francisco, a
local and national television
and radio guest,
a freelance writer
for several publications,
including "Food & Wine
Magazine," and a wildly
passionate educator
about the basics of
cheese and wine pairing.
So thank you very much
for coming today, Laura.
I appreciate having you.
LAURA WERLIN: Oh, I
appreciate being here.
Thank you.
JASON CRANE: Do you want
to give us a little bit
of your background,
and then we'll--
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah.
Well, so as you said, I've
written six books about cheese.
And prior to that actually,
I wasn't in cheese at all.
I was in TV news.
I wasn't on camera.
I was behind the scenes.
But I always, always,
always loved food.
And I always wrote
about it on the side.
So I would take trips,
and I would say,
today we saw the Eiffel Tower.
And that'd be like
one little paragraph,
and 15 pages later
is what we ate.
So I decided that I wanted
to go into food writing.
And then, not long
after that, I wanted
to write about cheese
because it was something
that I loved, and
also specifically
American cheese because
what I noticed, living here
in northern
California, that there
were these amazing
cheeses being made here.
And I wanted to bring
attention to those.
But then what I realized is
that what was happening here
in northern California was
happening all over the country.
And I thought, I'm going to
write about American cheese.
I need to tell the story.
And I felt like we were kind
on the cusp of an evolution,
or revolution really, with
cheesemaking in this country.
And that book came
out 14 years ago.
So in fact, that's kind
of what's happening
is American cheese
making has exploded.
JASON CRANE: Yeah,
it really has.
So that kind of leads me
into my first question.
So six books on cheese.
What about cheese keeps
drawing you back over and over
to write these cookbooks?
And as we were discussing
a little bit at lunch,
two of them are
on grilled cheese.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah, yeah.
Well, what keeps drawing me
back to cheese is cheese itself.
I got into in the
first place really
because it got into me
because I love cheese.
And I always have,
ever since I was just
the tiniest little kid.
In fact, my first memory
is of a grilled cheese
sandwich, my first food memory.
That and Cheerios, I think.
But one of the neat
things about cheese
is that it's not a
subject you can really
master because it's so complex.
It's kind of like wine.
If you love wine, you
don't really tire of it.
You don't tire of
learning about it
because there's so much to know.
And cheese is the same way.
And what I've learned
over the years
is that there are so many
different kinds of cheeses.
And now, in the US,
so many new kinds
of cheeses because there
are new cheesemakers
popping up everywhere
and all the time.
And so every time I take a
bite of cheese or every time
I see cheese being
made, I learn so much.
And so it's never
boring, and it's
so fundamentally
satisfying to me
to eat a really great
piece of cheese.
So I can't imagine
ever tiring of it.
JASON CRANE: I
agree 100% with you.
I haven't had a cheese
I haven't liked yet.
LAURA WERLIN: Right.
Well, I've met a couple
cheeses I haven't liked.
But as a category,
I like cheese a lot.
JASON CRANE: Awesome.
So today we were working from
your "Mac & Cheese, Please!"
book.
And they were doing some
mac and cheeses here
in the cafe for the Googlers
to come through and eat.
And we started talking about
comfort food a little bit.
And I kind of wanted
to get your thoughts
on what you thought
comfort food was,
and what's
specifically about mac
and cheese and grilled
cheese that just really fits
that comfort food model.
LAURA WERLIN: Well, I think that
comfort food is comfort food
because it evokes a memory
without even thinking about it.
It's subconscious.
So you have this just
visceral response
to a food that makes you think
of home, whatever that is,
or something really,
really positive.
Comfort food does not
evoke a negative thought.
Right?
JASON CRANE: Right
LAURA WERLIN: Because
then it's not comforting.
Right?
And a big bubbling
cauldron of mac and cheese,
it might not be
gourmet mac and cheese.
It's probably, in fact, if
it evokes those memories,
it's probably not that.
It's probably something
that was in a pot that
might have even
come out of a box.
And grilled cheese
is the same way.
In both cases, both mac and
cheese and grilled cheese--
Actually, I really feel
this way particularly
about grilled cheese.
--it hits all the senses.
So you've got this aroma when
grilled cheese is being made.
And then you have
texture because you've
got this crunchy bread, and
you've got this gooey cheese.
Then you also have the
visual because something
is priming you.
When you look at
that, when you see
that cheese oozing and the
crunchy bread and all that,
you just kind of know it's
going to be pretty fantastic.
Right?
And then, of course, the aroma.
Did I say that?
And then you've got,
of course, flavor.
Right?
So it hits just all of
those parts of ourselves
that are fundamental
to being human beings.
And then, add to that the
component of memory, which
I think a lot of
people have memories
of both mac and cheese
and grilled cheese
as kids, mostly positive.
Although I have to be honest,
I didn't like mac and cheese
as a kid.
I didn't like
noodles of any kind.
And that changed.
But it's a positive memory.
And I don't think
there's any way
to separate food from
memory, particularly when
it's positive.
And there really isn't.
And so that's why some
people say they still
prefer mac and cheese out
of the box in some ways,
even though they're
grown ups now,
and they love great
cheese and all that.
It's because you can't fight
with mom or at least whatever
the memory is that you have.
JASON CRANE: Exactly.
Yeah.
As far as texture goes, I
always put too much cheese
in my grilled cheeses.
LAURA WERLIN: Is
there a such thing?
JASON CRANE: That cheese that
spills out and then gets crispy
on the bottom of the pan
right next to the sandwich.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah, Yeah.
JASON CRANE: That's one
of my favorite parts
of the grilled cheese.
LAURA WERLIN: Well,
that's why I recommend
when you make a grilled
cheese sandwich to use
a non-stick pan because
for just that reason.
Because who wants to
have to wash it off?
You want to eat it off?
Right?
JASON CRANE: Before the
sandwich is even done.
LAURA WERLIN: Before
the sandwich is done.
It's a snack.
JASON CRANE: So while we're
talking about the book,
what recipe in the
book was your favorite
to eat and do the
research on and cook?
LAURA WERLIN: Oh gosh.
That's kind of akin to
asking your favorite child.
Right?
Of course I don't have
children, so that parts easy.
I don't have to choose.
But yeah, with the mac and
cheese, one of my favorites,
I do really have a few in there.
But one of my
favorites is one that I
call butternut squash and
Gruyere mac and cheese.
So what you do is you
roast the butternut squash,
and then you kind of
mash it and add that
to the cream and cheese.
And then you make a sage butter.
So you take fresh sage leaves
and just fry them real quickly
in butter, and then all of that
goes into the mac and cheese
too.
So it's a really, really
wonderful fall dish.
Plus you've got the orange
color from the butternut squash.
And then there are
these bread crumbs
that are mixed with
Parmesan on top.
So you got the crunch, and
you've got the cheesiness,
and you've got the visual.
And it's great on a
Thanksgiving table.
And even though,
of course, there
are a few other foods on
the Thanksgiving table.
But it kind of almost takes the
place of stuffing, not quite.
But it works really
well side by side.
JASON CRANE: So cheese has
come a long way in America
over the last 10,
15 years since you
wrote your first book on it.
Can we talk a little bit
about some of the changes
that have happened to
the cheese industry
and where Americans have come
in their taste for cheese?
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
When I was saying before
about there being a cheese
revolution in America,
that kind of cuts
across all swaths of cheese.
And so what I mean by that is
that the American cheesemaker
has evolved.
Even what we call
cheese has evolved.
So when I was first
writing about this,
or researching it
actually, 15 years ago,
I took myself to the
annual conference
of the American Cheese Society.
And at the time,
they have something
called the Festival of Cheese.
And I went around, and I tasted.
They had maybe 300 cheeses out.
And I got to about 299 of them.
That 300th jalapeno cheddar
I just couldn't get to.
But the point is that there
were not that many cheeses.
And those that were there were
a lot of the flavored ones, not
so fabulous cheeses.
There were several
that were good though.
And now, that same conference,
it's held annually,
has almost 1,800 cheeses
at that same festival.
And it isn't just a
matter of quantity.
It's also quality.
So the cheese
itself has evolved.
The skill of the cheesemaker
has evolved tremendously.
And there's been
attrition as well.
So some of the
cheesemakers that were
doing things the same way
for a generation or two--
We don't have a long
tradition of cheesemaking
in this country.
--but for those who were,
either were phased out
or they had to step
up to the plate
and revise their cheesemaking
methods that they've
been doing for 20 or
40 or 60 years, however
many generations, because the
American palate was evolving.
And that jalapeno cheddar--
Not that there's
anything wrong with that.
I mean, there's certain
flavored cheeses I really like.
--it just didn't cut
the mustard as it were.
And then also what
we name cheeses.
So if you think about the
evolution of American wine,
wine drinkers in
America, for a long time,
looked down their
nose at American wine.
They thought, no, the real stuff
comes from France, maybe Italy.
And that's where they
looked to get their wine.
And little by
little, it was clear
that California wine
was pretty darn good.
And of course, we now know
that that's well established.
But in addition to looking
within our own borders
for wine, the winemakers here
started naming their wines--
Originally, they were
Burgundy and Chablis,
which those are
regions in France.
And they mean nothing to us.
--So the American winemakers
started calling their wines
Chardonnay and Pinot
Noir, after the grape
with which it was made.
So originally,
American cheesemakers
were naming their cheeses
after some sort of loose recipe
they were making, based
on an old world cheese,
like Gruyere or something.
The problem was that the
American consumer would
eat that so-called Gruyere,
and it tasted nothing
like the Swiss version.
So little by little, American
cheesemakers realized
that they were doing
themselves no service
by naming their cheeses
after the old world
versions, to which there's
was not even similar.
So now, they name them
anything, like after the lane
on which they live or the creek
nearby, or whatever it is,
which is slightly confusing
for the American consumer
because it's hard to remember.
By the same token,
it distinguishes
those cheesemakers,
as it should.
And it also changed the
consumer's expectation
of what that cheese is.
If they read that
it's My Farm's Cheese,
they're not going
to try to fit it
in any box of the
cheese they've had
previously that
might be similar.
They just accept it on its face.
And so that's been, I
think, a really big change
in terms of American
cheesemaking.
And the other thing is that
American cheesemakers are not
bound by tradition.
Good news, bad news.
So what that means is that
we have had to learn--
I mean, I'm not a
cheesemaker, but collectively.
--have had to learn skills
that were not passed down
the way they had been
for hundreds of years
in the old world.
And that's the good
news and the bad news.
So in a way, they're inventing
the wheel here, which is good.
But there's a big
learning curve.
But on the other hand, they
come up with these recipes
that no old world,
traditional cheesemaker,
who was bound by tradition,
would ever think to make.
So we're the really, those
of us that love cheese,
are the lucky
beneficiaries of that.
JASON CRANE: So
while we're talking
about all these types
of cheese, there
are so many that can
be really intimidating.
And you were just talking
a little bit about this
with a lot of it's not grounded.
We know our cheddar.
We know our swiss.
But what is Redwood
Hill Camellia?
There's no connection to
anything real in that.
And how do we, as
consumers and eaters,
get over some of
that Intimidation?
LAURA WERLIN: Well, part
of it is just to be brave.
Be brave with your cheese.
It won't bite back.
Well, most of the time anyway.
That stuff that's sitting in
the back of your refrigerator
that has green mold
on it, maybe not.
But the rest of it.
So it really is about getting
it in your mouth, tasting it.
And what that requires
is going to a store,
could be Whole Foods or it could
be a cheese shop, where they're
willing to give you samples.
Beyond that though,
I did write a book
called Cheese Essentials.
And in that, what I talk about
are the styles of cheese.
So familiarizing
yourself with styles.
What does that mean?
A fresh cheese.
So that can be ricotta
product or fresh goat cheese
or something like that.
If you know the
basic characteristics
of a fresh cheese, then
you can look in the case
and say, OK, I think
I know that this
is going to be not too salty.
It's going to be a
little bit tangy.
little milk-like,
the milk from which it came.
A soft, ripened cheese.
Another word, really a
fancy description for brie.
So that's the kind that
has the white, bloomy rind.
If you know you like brie,
next time you go to the store,
don't buy brie.
Buy a cheese that
looks like brie,
and expand your horizons,
because chances are it's
not going to be so very
different from that brie
that you like.
And the worst case
scenario is that it
isn't as good as the
one that you like,
so then at least you've
branched out a little bit.
JASON CRANE: A
frame of reference
for the next cheese you try.
LAURA WERLIN: Exactly.
I also recommend trying cheeses
side by side, the same style.
So buy three blue cheeses
if you like blue cheese.
Of course, don't
do it if you don't.
Or three cheddars.
And you can recognize
the difference in flavor,
in texture, and see
what appeals to you.
And the more you do
that, the more familiar
you're going to become
with those styles.
And what that means is
that you can go to Paris
and go to a cheese shop there.
And you can look and say, hey,
that's a soft, ripened cheese.
I know that because I can
just look at that white ,
so-called bloomy rind, and I
don't care that I don't read
French or that I don't
know that producer.
I'm going to try that.
And it's important to
know the milk source,
to know that if you do or don't
like goats milk, for instance.
But beyond that, once you learn
those styles or conversely
a style that a
lot of people have
either an attraction
or an avoidance
to is called a
washed rind cheese.
So that has the
orangish kind of rind.
They're kind of sticky,
and they're very creamy.
So a cheese like Taleggio or
Epoisse from France or Red
Hawk from Cowgirl Creamery
here in California.
They will stink up
your refrigerator
almost instantaneously.
And they smell.
They kind of are
counterintuitive.
You think, why would
I eat something
that smells like old gym socks?
But in fact, if you like
that style of cheese,
they're really good.
And I do too.
But if you don't, that's an
entire section of the cheese
store that you can just say,
mm-mm, don't want to go there.
And so once you know
that that's the style,
then you can go or not
go depending on that.
So it's really about
learning styles.
I mean, yes, cheeses
vary within styles.
So a semi-hard category of
cheeses, you've got cheddar
and you've got Gruyere,
and you've got Emmentaler,
like the quintessential
sort of Swiss cheese.
Those are very different
from each other.
But some of the
characteristics are similar.
They melt well.
And really the only way to
know though is to taste.
JASON CRANE: OK.
So just be adventurous, and
get out there and keep trying.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah.
And like I said,
don't be intimidated.
Because I do understand
people's reluctance
because it could be a
strong smelling food.
But I just think that people
should be a little bit braver
because most cheeses
really aren't going
to be as strong as they
smell, no matter what.
And I think that people
are going to be pleasantly
surprised more times than not.
JASON CRANE: What are some uses
for cheeses that we might not
have thought about
that someone who's
done all this research can?
LAURA WERLIN: Well, one
of the things about cheese
is it is very versatile.
Obviously, there are the things
that we have thought about,
those that we've
talked about today,
and we all know
on top of a pizza.
In fact, more cheese is sold
in this country than any other,
I mean more mozzarella, because
it lands on top of a pizza.
And there's nothing wrong
with that by the way.
Although I like burrata.
Mix it up a little.
Anyway, you can make ice cream.
I recently had brie ice cream.
I did not make it, but I had it.
And did I love it?
No.
But it just goes to show
that cheese is versatile.
And other people at
my table loved it,
and I thought, all right.
Well, whatever.
But cheese and chocolate
are really, really,
really compatible.
And blue cheese in particular
and dark chocolate,
add a little candied
ginger, and you've
got this confection that
is just this dessert that's
like a cheese course,
but it's a dessert course
that's all in one.
And some people might
not think so much
of pairing cheese and chocolate.
I've met many people along
the way that love cheese,
and they love chocolate,
but they haven't necessarily
thought of putting
them together.
But you should.
And part of it, if you
think about eating trends
right now, particularly
chocolate or desserts
in general, there's a lot
of salt now that we find.
You know, salted caramel,
salted chocolate.
So why not cheese?
Because that's got that
savory, salty component.
Or a smoked cheese
and chocolate.
Sometimes you'll see smoked
salt on chocolate, same idea.
But you've got texture
going on there too.
So beyond that, I don't know.
I suppose you could
use certain cheeses
to like plug a whole or
something in your sink.
I don't know.
I don't know what else
I would use cheese
for other than
mostly the obvious.
I don't know.
Can you think of anything?
JASON CRANE: You nailed a
couple of good ones there.
But usually cheese doesn't
make it much past the knife
that I cut it off
the block with.
That's usually most of the time.
If it makes it onto a
nice everything cracker,
I'm like that's
double bonus round.
LAURA WERLIN:
Right, right, right.
Or if it's a creamy
cheese, it doesn't even
get on to a cracker.
It just stays on my spoon.
And I do use a
spoon, not a knife
when it's a creamy cheese.
But that is another
thing though.
I think sometimes we overthink
how cheese should be used here
because it is something
that we celebrate
and something that
we revere really.
I think sometimes
we overthink it,
and then that's part of
the intimidation factor.
So I actually taught
a class last night,
and somebody was asking
me when to serve cheese.
Before dinner?
After dinner?
JASON CRANE: Both
LAURA WERLIN:
Well, yeah or both?
Right.
Well, there is a place for
it at both ends of the meal.
And what I found
is that you just
don't want to
overwhelm people with--
I mean, what happens is if
you serve it beforehand,
people go crazy with it.
Right?
For one, that's when
they're hungriest.
But two, it's always exciting
to have a selection of cheeses.
And then you eat dinner, and
then you have cheese again,
maybe, and then you're full.
And everybody blames the cheese.
Well, I'm sorry.
What about those short
ribs and that caesar salad
and everything else you ate?
But so what I try
to do is I might
have one cheese after dinner.
But it's a cheese that
I've really sought out,
I think is really special.
And then I'll put an
accompaniment with it
that I think is
really complementary.
And there might
be a dessert wine
or it might be the wine that was
with the main course at dinner
that we just carry over,
or whatever it might be.
So having one
cheese after dinner
is, I think, a
different use for cheese
than most people think of.
But I will tell you, having
done this more than once, when
people, if they call you
the next day to thank you
for the dinner party, which
hopefully they've done,
then they will always
say, oh my god.
What was that cheese?
Not wow, the whole
rest of the meal
that you made that you
spent hours or days making
was so fabulous.
I love the cheese you bought.
I'm like, thanks.
But so really that's a way
to make cheese special.
And you're not investing your
life savings in it either.
And that's also a
really great way to go.
JASON CRANE: Yeah,
that's a great idea.
My wife's a pastry chef.
There's always that
whenever there's
a cheese course
available, I'd rather
have cheese for dessert
than actual dessert most
of the time.
LAURA WERLIN: A lot
of people would.
And you know what, it's
also a helpful thing
as people go gluten
free more and more.
So many desserts have gluten
in some way, shape, or form.
And also for
diabetics too, cheese
is a wonderful alternative.
And I've found that
over the years,
that people that have health
reasons for not eating sweets
just love the fact that the
cheese course is finally
making its way onto
the American table.
JASON CRANE: So let's
talk a little bit
about actually getting in and
making these mac and cheeses
a little bit here and some
of the technical details.
There's a section in your book
where you go through and give
us the lowdown on some of the
ingredients and the correct way
to use them.
So my first question
about this is,
why does the fat content in the
milk you use matter so much?
And what do you find is the best
either milk or mixture of dairy
products that really
bring that sauce together?
LAURA WERLIN: Well,
you know, writing a mac
and cheese book was definitely
an exercise in indulgence.
I will not kid you.
But I did write a chapter
called, Lighten Up, Cool Down.
So the rest of the book
celebrates cream and whole milk
and all of that.
But that chapter,
I used skim milk
for the most part, a
little bit of low fat too.
The issue there is it's tricky.
When you have a lower
fat or no fat milk,
the cheese has a
tendency to curdle.
And you have to add
the milk really slowly.
And add the milk,
I mean to a flour--
JASON CRANE: To
your roux, right?
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah, to the
roux, the butter/flour mixture
or oil/flour, olive oil.
So you add the milk slowly.
And you do it over a lower heat.
And hopefully the
cheese won't curdle.
The other component,
when I mentioned flour,
that's crucial when you're
using a lower fat or nonfat milk
because it basically keeps the
proteins from matting together
to curdle, which in the presence
of starch that's what happens.
JASON CRANE: There's not
enough fat to get in the way.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah.
JASON CRANE: With whole milk
fats, you have all that fat.
And the cheese has fat.
And then you block that.
LAURA WERLIN: That's
exactly right.
So you can do it.
It's just trickier to cook with.
But in terms of just
the voluptuousness
I think that we think
of for mac and cheese,
I really do like to
have a full fat--
You don't have to use cream.
Whole milk is great.
I mean, this is one of
the things I've learned.
It's very forgiving.
You can use different
variety of milks or just one,
and you're going to be OK.
But I do think that
there should be
just a little fat in there
somewhere for flavor,
but also just so that your
mac and cheese will work.
What else?
Oh, yeah.
Also, of course you know you
want to grate the cheese.
Some people believe that
when you add the cheese
to that bechamel, to that white
sauce, that you should do it
off the heat.
And there are reasons for that.
Although, I found that
I didn't really have to.
I just put it in, stirred it
until it melted, and then you
add the cooked pasta
and go from there,
whatever other ingredients.
JASON CRANE: I think
that comes into if you're
bechamel is screaming hot,
you could break the cheese.
But if you're at a
mid-range temperature,
it doesn't really have
to come off the heat.
It kind of just depends
on your cooking method.
LAURA WERLIN: That's
exactly right.
Yeah.
And if it's the whole
thing does break,
meaning separates and curdles,
then it's so disappointing.
JASON CRANE: It's a sad moment.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah.
It is a sad moment.
Yeah.
JASON CRANE: So talk
about the different kind
of cheeses and where
to use them in the mac.
LAURA WERLIN: Well, I
was going to say also
one of the things
about mac and cheese,
and grilled cheese too,
it's kind of a blank canvas.
You can paint it with
whatever ingredients
you might have on hand.
Or if you're at the farmer's
market, and you see broccoli,
you think how does broccoli
work in the mac and cheese?
But what I did, I
made a broccoli.
I did a rip on broccoli
cheddar casserole
with the mac and cheese.
So instead, you can use
the canned, fried onions
that are typically on top.
Right.
JASON CRANE: Delicious.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah.
But I happened to provide a
recipe for fried shallots.
They're super simple, but
you don't have to use them.
But they're great.
And then the broccoli
and the cheddar,
and a little cayenne,
a little spice, but all
with the macaroni,
it's a great way to go.
But in terms of the cheeses
that you use for mac and cheese,
as with grilled cheese,
essentially any cheese
will work, but they
work in different ways.
So a very hard
cheese, like Parmesan,
that's not going
to be oozy, gooey.
Right?
So what you use that for--
Or pecorino.
--you might mix that
with some bread crumbs
and put them right on top.
So you get that toasty,
nutty kind of cheesy flavor.
But again, you're
looking for that crunch.
You're not looking for the pull.
And then say you want to
use brie or blue cheese.
Those get creamy, but
they don't get stretchy.
So what I like to do is I'll
put a creamy cheese like that,
or goat cheese, in
a mac and cheese,
but then I also add
a pullable cheese,
like a mozzarella or something
or Gruyere or whatever,
something like
that because I like
to have a little
bit of that stretch
with mac and cheese, as well
as, again, grilled cheese.
So really any cheese will lend
itself to a mac and cheese.
It just depends on the
results you're looking for
and, of course, the flavor.
And I mentioned brie
in this context.
That's one of those cheeses,
when it has a rind like that,
you want to cut that
off because that
doesn't melt in the same way.
It becomes like little paper
pieces, which is not so great.
JASON CRANE: Let me just
put that on a cracker
and just eat the rind while
you're making the cheese.
LAURA WERLIN:
Well, I'm with you.
I'm glad to hear you say that
because so many people are
so afraid of the rind.
And I don't know about you,
but I've gone to many parties
where there's this
wheel of brie.
And everybody digs
out the center.
JASON CRANE: It's all dug out.
LAURA WERLIN: Don't do that.
Just cut the whole
piece that you want.
Put it on your napkin.
You can dig it out yourself.
And wrap the rest
up, and I don't
care, put it under
your host's pillow.
Just don't leave
it on the table.
JASON CRANE: So the next
part, and it's not really
mac and cheese without the mac.
Talk a little bit about
pastas and the kind of pastas
and sizes and shapes
that lend themselves
more to making a mac and cheese.
LAURA WERLIN: Well, what
I found when I made it--
So, first of all, let
me explain my definition
of mac and cheese.
Even though it's mac
and cheese, in my world
it's really cheese and mac.
OK.
So I want the cheese
to really sing.
So if you have big, big pasta,
then it becomes a pasta dish
with cheese, which there's
nothing wrong with.
But to me, at that point, it
ceases to be mac and cheese.
So I decided to go for
smaller shapes and sizes.
The largest I use
is penne, which
is just the ridged, little
tubular cheese, which
is kind of the maximum.
And part of the reason I
use that in certain recipes
is because the ridges
on the outside of penne
are meant to absorb sauce.
And I like the
toothsomeness of pasta.
I want that to be there.
I just don't want that to
be the overwhelming texture.
It's not so much about
flavor, but texture.
And so the ratio of
sauce to pasta I felt
worked better with
slightly smaller pasta.
So that could be like the
tiny or the small elbow
macaroni, the traditional.
In a couple recipes I do
call for the bigger one,
but mostly I like the smaller.
Or it might be the
small shell pasta.
Just smaller shapes,
in general, I
found were the better
way to go to get
that cheesiness to dominate.
JASON CRANE: So we
talked a little bit
about the healthy
chapter at the end.
What do we call it?
LAURA WERLIN: Oh,
Lighten Up, Cool Down.
JASON CRANE: Lighten
Up, Cool Down.
Did you have any
rhyme or reason to why
you named the chapters
the way you did?
Because they were kind of
fun as I was reading through,
and it kind of broke the book
down into some nice sections
for what you were maybe looking
for different uses for the mac.
LAURA WERLIN: Well,
with that chapter,
I conceived of it initially
as a recipe for days
like we're having today,
where it's nearly 100 degrees.
And I thought, can you have a
hot day and your mac and cheese
on the same day?
And I felt like the
easiest way to do
that was to make for a
lighter substance, so
nonfat low fat milk, and, in a
couple cases, lower fat cheese,
which again is a little tricky
to work with because it doesn't
melt so well, or as
well I should say.
And so I don't know.
That chapter title
just came to me.
Eat Your Veggies.
So here we have this sort
of inherently decadent book.
Right?
Mac and cheese.
But I still want you
to eat your veggies.
So that's the chapter that
has all vegetable related
macs and cheese.
And Eat Your Protein.
That too, sure, go ahead
and get your sausage.
I have one that's
meatballs, and it's actually
a riff on meatballs
and spaghetti, which
is what I call it.
But it's in quotes.
So it meatballs and
burrata and a tomato sauce
in macaroni, or
some sort of pasta.
I can't remember which one.
It's very decadent, and
it's very delicious.
So anyway, but that's
in the protein chapter.
And there's a classic.
And then there's
an almost classic,
because it was kind of
a riff on the classic.
So in that section--
I think it's in that
section or chapter.
--I have just a mac and cheese.
I think it has a little
smoky paprika in it.
And then I also have a
grilled cheese recipe there.
And that's what you use to dip
to get the Mac and cheese out.
Decadent?
Oh, yeah.
JASON CRANE: Absolutely.
LAURA WERLIN: Starchy?
Oh, yeah.
Forget about the gluten thing.
If you're gluten
free, I'm sorry.
Well, actually that's
not really true.
You can use gluten free
bread and gluten free pasta,
and you can still enjoy it.
JASON CRANE: You just have to
be a little bit more careful.
And obviously, if you're
living that lifestyle
you know to be a little
more careful with the rice
pastas or the quinoa pastas
that don't quite hold up as well
to cooking as regular pastas.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah, you
just have to be careful.
JASON CRANE: Did we
have any questions?
AUDIENCE: If you had
to pick one cheese--
JASON CRANE: The question was,
with all these great cheeses
we're talking about and all
the cheeses you've tried,
if you had to pick one cheese
to take to a desert island
with you, what
cheese would that be?
On the spot.
LAURA WERLIN: Oh my gosh.
I hate to answer that
question because there are so
many thousands of cheeses,
not only that I love.
You know what, I will answer it.
I'm going to dodge it, but I'll
answer it at the same time.
So what I find is that,
when a cheese is really,
really, really well made--
And what I mean by
that, you might think,
well, I know what a well made
cheese is, but you might not.
What I mean by
that is, I'll never
forget this experience, where I
was eating a fresh goat cheese.
A simple cheese right?
And it was made just
outside of Austin, Texas,
famous cheesemaking
region, not so much.
And I know the cheesemaker,
and she hand ladles,
hand pours the curds
into this mold.
But it was a fresh chevre,
or fresh goat cheese.
I tasted it, and I thought,
it rocked my world.
At that moment in
time, that would
have been my desert
island cheese
because that's when I realized
that fresh chevre was not
like--
I mean that could be just a
special as a cheese that's
aged in the mountains of
France for a year and a half.
Now, speaking of
mountains in France,
although American cheese is my
first love there is a cheese
called Comte, C-O-M-T-E,
that I think is absolutely
spectacular.
I love Comte.
And it tastes great
just by itself.
It melts really well.
And so that would be a
cheese I could consider.
And then on this side
of the Atlantic--
I know I'm saying more
than one, but I have to.
Oh my gosh.
On this side of the Atlantic,
there are about a million.
But if I were staying
with that style of cheese,
there are actually two.
One is made in Vermont,
and it's a newish cheese
by a wonderful
place called Cellars
at Jasper Hill and
Jasper Hill Farm.
Their kind of the same.
The Cellars is they blasted out
a cave in their hill in Vermont
to create cheese aging caves.
And they not only age their
own cheese that they make there
on the farm, but they also age
other people in the region's.
Very small cheesemakers, so it's
been a unique model in the US.
And what it does is it
allows them to not only make
the local cheeses,
some of them, really
make them better because
those cheesemakers might not
know how.
But it also allows
those cheesemakers
to find a market because they
don't have the distribution
capabilities that
Jasper Hill does.
So what they do it
they age those cheeses.
And so they have this cheese
that they make themselves
that Jasper Hill makes
called Alpha Tolman.
It's named after, I don't
know, somebody in their region.
A-L-P-H-A and then T-O-L-M-A-N.
It's a delicious alpine style
cheese that, I'm telling
you, get your hands on it.
It's worth it.
But then the other
domestic cheese that I--
An other, not the other.
--that I love is
made in Wisconsin.
And it's a cheese called
Pleasant Ridge Reserve.
And it too is an
alpine style cheese.
It's modeled after a cheese
from France called Beaufort,
B-E-A-U-F-O-R-T.
And Pleasant Ridge Reserve
is a model of cheesemaking.
It represents so
much because it's
a cheese that is made
only from spring to fall
when the cows are
out on pasture.
They do rotational
grazing, which
means that the cows are moved
from different paddocks.
As the cows eat the
grass, it gets down
to a level where the cheesemaker
thinks that the grass is not
really feeding the cow the
nutrients that it should
to make for the best milk,
and therefore the best cheese.
So then they move the cows
on, let the grass grow back.
So it's a model of
sustainability as well.
And what happens is that
the milk is so fantastic, ,
and the cheese, of course,
is too because of how good
the milk is.
And it's all really healthy
and healthful for the cows
and for the land, and
ultimately for us.
And it's a magnificent cheese.
I mean, I can't say anything.
I can't say enough about it.
JASON CRANE: Well, awesome.
I think that's a great way to
tie up our conversation today.
I really appreciate
you coming out
to visit us here at
Google today, and everyone
in the cafe who got to eat lunch
and try your delicious recipes,
and thank everyone here for
coming to listen to our talk
today.
And it was really
nice seeing you again.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah,
you too, Jason.
JASON CRANE: And enjoy
the rest of your day.
LAURA WERLIN: I
will I really will.
Thank you so much.
You're
JASON CRANE: Welcome.
LAURA WERLIN: Yeah.